merci beaucoup nous travaillons très
étroitement avec tous nos partenaires
européens et en particulier nos
partenaires britanniques nous sommes en
train de finaliser un accord de stp qui
sera signé dans les prochaines
semaines bilatéral permettant en effet
des éléments de
garantie nous allons procéder à des
livraisons nouvelles une quarantaine de
missiles scalp et plusieurs centaines de
bombes attendu par nos amis
Ukrainiens nous avons aussi développé
des production dans ce casre de
l'économie de guerre qui vont permettre
de fournir beaucoup plus de matériel à
nos partenaires Ukrainiens en
particulier des Césars qui sont attendus
et nécessaires et donc nous allons au
fond continuer d'aider l'Ukraine dans
ses
besoins de
formation pour tenir sur le front et
pour défendre son ciel avec les
livraisons que j'évoqué avec les accords
que nous finaliserons j'irai moi-même en
février en Ukraine j'annoncerai la
finalisation de ces textes les
livraisons de munitions que j'évoque là
seront commencé et à chaque fois que
nous nous annonçons nous faisons
quasiment en temps réel comme vous le
savez et nous aurons très clairement
nous Français et nous Européens à
prendre des décisions nouvelles dans les
semaines et les mois qui
viennent précisément pour ne pas laisser
la Russie
gagner